journalist glenn greenwald has been
watching this particular operation for a
long time
way back in 2015 and we looked it up
today glenn greenwald was writing about
the intelligence community's pivot to
identity politics
with a clarity that seems almost
clairvoyant today
i wish we'd listened to him then he
joins us now glenn greenwald of substack
glenn i hate to say it once again you
called it before anyone else i've ever
read
you pointed out six years ago that the
so-called intel community cia
in particular was using a particular
kind of ruling class
politics to cloak the fact they were
doing what they've done for decades
yeah i mean obviously part of it the
most superficial part is that it's just
a branding exercise right so
corporations waive the black lives
matter flag you forget about the fact
that they produce their products and
swept
sweatshops and with slave labor the cia
base itself and the rainbow flag and you
forget about all the coups and
assassinations that they do
but also it shows that left-wing
cultural ideology is the dominant
ideology that's why they're appealing to
that
as their branding mark rather than say
right-wing ideology but there's
something more substantive
tucker which is that it used to be in
the cold war that it was the left that
distrusted the cia
hated the cia and the right loved it
that has completely reversed
if you look at polling data it's
democrats and liberals who love the cia
because the cia was on their side
during the entire trump era and so the
people at the cia
this really is their ideology it's the
ideology of the democratic party it's
not a radical ideology it's the ideology
of power
there's another amazing video of john
brennan besides the one that you played
where he went on msnbc and said
i'm humiliated to be a white man
they really believe this ideology it's
ruling class ideology even though
leftists believe
it's the it's the ideology of liberation
and i think the most important thing is
wokeness this ideology is not about
subverting
power centers they never talk about
power centers the cia
big tech monopolies hedge fund managers
it's about turning citizens against one
another
that person is evil that individual is
bad it empowers
these ruling class centers that's why
they not just embrace it and cynically
exploit it they actually finance it
and want to spread it because it
strengthens and entrenches their power
well i have sort of noticed from the
very beginning that all these attacks on
law enforcement which
you know on some level are pushing back
against people with power and i think
that's a really healthy and important
thing to do
but they're only about local police
departments no one ever mentions these
massive
incredibly heavily armed federal
agencies with subpoena power
that can kill you actually if they
wanted to and no one
ever on television pushes back against
them put the ca in that category is that
kind of the thinking that you're
describing
american liberalism and the left have a
complete confusion
about where power lies so like you look
at groups like antifa which say
we're this radical edgy aggressive group
that's going to stand up to
fasterism they never go and protest at
langley at the cia headquarters they
never challenge
the pentagon they're nowhere near
silicon valley or wall street they think
power lies with like
the boogaloo boys and and and and those
kind of groups you know the proud boys
those are who they go and fight that's
where they think power lies these big
institutions that are heavily armed that
rule the federal government that are
designed to entrench ruling class elite
interests
they don't care about white supremacy or
transphobia or any of that they're more
than happy
to integrate as many people as want to
join them into it
but the left and liberals think that
they're fighting against power when
they're really fighting marginalized
people
to benefit ruling in class institutions
because it's much easier
to go fight a boogaloo boy than the cia
or or
tech monopolies in the end when you're
droned
will it make you feel better if an
intersectional person is at the controls
there's actually a a hilarious cartoon
that was circulated by the left
where two people in yemen a couple are
looking up at a drone as a bomb drops
and say
i hear that the next bomb that they're
going to send is one that's going to be
sent by a woman and they're smiling and
all happy
because it's now diversity that's uh the
face of militarism
i just love that that's the best glenn
greenwald i
i can't overstate how prescient you were
on this topic as on many others and i
would
i would hope that our people watching
would look it up thank you
thank you tucker hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else